what I want to do in this video is to
make two parametrizations of essentially
the same curve but we're going to go
along the curve at different rates and
hopefully we'll be able to use that to
understand or get a better intuition
behind what exactly it means to take a
derivative of a position vector-valued
function so let's say my first parameter
is a ssin I have X of T is equal to T
and let's say that Y of T is equal to T
squared and this is true for T is
greater than or equal to zero and less
than or equal to two and if I want to
write this as a position vector valued
function let me write this X 1 let me
call that y 1 and let me write my
position vector valued function I could
say R 1 because I'm numbering them
because I'm going to a different version
of this exact same curve with a slightly
different parametrizations so R 1 of T
we could say is X 1 of T times I the
position the unit vector I so we'll just
say T times I plus write this is just X
of T right here or X 1 of T that's the
numbering because I later have an X 2 of
T plus T squared plus T squared times J
and if I wanted to if I wanted to graph
this I'm going to be very careful
graphing it because I really want to
understand what the derivative means
here let me get my draw try to draw it
too roughly to scale so let's say that
this is so we get 1 2 3 4 and then let
me draw my x-axis that's good enough and
my x-axis I want it to be roughly to
scale 1 and 2 and so at T equals 0 both
my x and y coordinates are at 0 or this
is just going to be the 0 vector so this
is where we are at T equals 0 at T
equals 1 this is going to be 1 times I
so we're going to be just like that plus
1 times J right 1 squared is J so we're
going to be right there and then at T is
e
equal to two we're going to be at two I
so - I you can imagine two times I would
be this vector right there right two
times I plus 4 right 2 squared is 4 4
times J so plus plus this plus 4 times J
right that's 4 times J if you add these
two vectors heads to tails you're going
to get a vector that goes that endpoint
is right there the vector is going to
look something like this I don't want to
so this is what just to make it clear
what we're doing that's our 1 of 2 right
this is our 1 of 0 this is our 1 of 1
but the bottom line is the path looks
like this it's a bit it's a parabola so
the path will look like that just like
that now that's in my first
parametrizations of it actually let me
draw a little bit more carefully I want
to get rid of this arrows just because I
want to be a nice clean drawing so my is
going to be a parabola that's that is so
let me get rid of that other point -
just because I didn't draw it exactly
where it needs to be it needs to be
right there and my parabola or my part
of my parabola is going to look
something like that
all right good enough so this is the
path the first parametrizations I'm
going to do this exact same curve but
I'm gonna do it slightly differently so
let's say I'll do it in different colors
so x2 of T let's say it equals 2t + y2
of T let's say it's equal to 2t squared
or we could alternatively write that
that's the same thing as 4t squared just
phrasing both of these guys to the
second power it's equal to 4t squared I
could write it either way and then let's
say my second parameter is age and let's
say instead of going from T equals 0 to
2 we're going to go from T goes from 0
to 1 T goes from 0 to 1 we're going to
see it's kind of we're going to cover
the exact same path and our second
vector of our position vector valued
function are 2 of T is going to be equal
to 2t times I
plus I can say 2t squared or 4t squared
times J and if I were to graph this guy
right here
it will look like let me draw my axes
again it's going to look the same but
it's I think useful to draw it because
I'm going to draw these the derivatives
and all of that on it later so let's see
one two three four one two and then
let's see what happens when T is equal
to zero when T is equal to 0 or R of 0
this all of these are going to be 0
we're just got the zero vector x and y
are both equal to 0 when T is equal to
1/2 so when T is equal to 1/2 what we're
going to get here 1/2 times 2 is 1 and
then we're going to get the point 1/2
squared is 1/4 times 4 is 1 so when T is
equal to 1/2 we're going to be at the
point 1 1 and when then T is equal to 1
we're going to be the point 2 4 right 2
4 so notice the curve is exactly the
path we go is exactly the same but
before we even do the derivatives these
two paths are identical I want to think
about something let's pretend that our
parameter T really is time that T is
equal to time and that tends to be the
most common that's why they call it T it
doesn't have to be time but let's say it
is time so what's happening here in this
first parametrizations when we go from 0
to 2 seconds we cover this path right
you can imagine after 1 second the dot
moves here then it moves there you can
imagine a dot moving along this curve
and it takes 2 seconds to do so in this
situation we have a dot moving along the
same curve but it's able to cover the
same curve and only one second and half
a second it gets here it took this guy 1
second to get here in 1 second this
guy's all the way over here this guy
takes 2 seconds to go over here so in
this second parametrizations even though
the path is the same the curves are the
same the dot is faster dot is faster and
i want you to keep that in mind when we
think about the
Rivet of both of these position
vector-valued functions so just remember
the dot is moving faster for every
second it's getting it's getting further
along the curve than here that's what
I'm I took them one second now let's
look at the derivatives of both of these
guys so the derivative here so if I were
to write R prime R prime R one prime of
T let me do it in a different color
actually or you use the orange so let me
do it in a blue R 1 prime of T so this
is the derivative now is going to be
remember it's just the derivative of
each of these times the unit vectors so
the derivative of of T with respect to T
that's just 1 so it's 1 times I so I'll
just write one I plus I didn't have to
write the 1 there plus the derivative of
T squared with respect to T is 2t plus
2t J and let me take the derivative over
here R 2 prime of T the derivative of 2t
with respect to T is 2 so 2i plus the
derivative of 4t squared is 8 T right 2
times 4 it is it is 8 t 8 t just like
that just like that now the question is
what do their what do their respective
of derivative vectors look like at
different points so let's look at I
don't know let's see let's see how fast
they're moving when time is equal to 1
so let's take let's take it a specific
point this is just the general formula
but let's take it let's figure out what
the derivative is at a specific point so
let's take our 1 when time is equal to
when time is equal to 1 and I want to
take the specific point on the curve not
the specific point in time so this point
on the curve here is when time is equal
to 1 you could say second this point
over here which is the exact
corresponding point is when time is
equal to 1/2 second so R 1 of 1 is equal
to I'm taking the derivative there is
equal to 1 i right it's not
t at all so it's 1 I plus 2 times 1 J so
plus 2 J so at this point the derivative
of or the derivative of our position
vector function is going to be 1 I plus
2 J so we can draw it like this so if we
do 1 I is like this one eye and then 2 J
just 2 J is like that so our derivative
right there I'll do it in the same color
that I wrote it in is in this green
color it's going to look like this it's
going to look like that and notice it
looks like at least its direction is let
me do it a little bit straighter its
direction that's not it
its direction looks tangent to the curve
it's going in the direction that my
particle is moving where my particle is
going from here to there so it's going
in the direction and I'm going to think
about in a second what this length of
this derivative vector is this right
here just to be clear is our one prime
it's a vector so it's the it's it's
telling us the instantaneous change in
our position vector with respect to T or
time when time is equal to one second
that's this thing right here now let's
take the exact same position here on our
curve but that's going to create a
different time for this guy we already
said it only takes him he's here at time
is equal to 1/2 second so let's take
let's take let me do it in a locket in
the same color so here we have r2 r2
we're going to evaluate at 1/2 because
it is that time is equal to 1/2 seconds
and this is going to be equal to 2i this
isn't dependent at all on time so 2i
plus 8 times the time so we're eight
time right here is 1/2 so 8 times 1/2 is
4 so plus 4j so what does this look like
the instantaneous derivative here oh and
this is the derivative you have to be
very clear so 2i that's let me draw some
more so to I maybe gets it's about that
far plus 4j will get us up to right
around there plus 4j is that vector so
you add those two heads to tails you get
this thing you get something
let me let me do it like you get
something that looks like that something
that looks like that I didn't draw it as
neatly as I would like to but let's
notice something both of these vectors
are going in the exact same direction
they're both tangential to the path to
our curve but this vector is going is
its length its magnitude is much larger
than this little vectors magnitude and
that makes sense because I hinted at it
when we first talked about these vector
valued position functions and their
derivatives is that the length the
length you can kind of view it as the
speed the length is equal to the speed
if you imagine time T being time and
this parametrizations are representing a
dot moving along these curves so in this
case the particle only takes a second to
go there so at this point in its path
it's moving much faster then this
particle is so if you think about it
this vector right here if you imagine
this is a position vector this is
velocity
this right here is velocity right
velocity is a speed plus direction speed
is just you know how fast are you going
velocity is how fast you're going in
what direction I'm going this fast in
and you could calculate it using
Pythagorean theorem but I just want to
give you the intuition right here I'm
going that fast in this direction here
I'm going this fast I'm going even
faster that's my magnitude but I'm still
going in the same direction so hopefully
you have a gut feeling now of what the
derivative of these position vectors
really are